hello everyone and welcome to a video
where i will be sharing some very
disturbing news that shook the chess
world at its core
uh magnus crossing is retiring from
chess not only from
professional chess but also from chess
in general now why this is so well
uh we uh to really understand this we
have to go back a few days uh not a few
days ago magnus carlsen posted a photo
on his instagram page uh this is the
photo that he posted
uh he was sort of chilling in the sun
meditating in front of the cult through
a palace in germany
uh where of course the uh the grenke
chess classic tournament uh
is happening every year and it's a bit
of a
grainy photo this is the palace actually
so you can check it out if you don't
know
but here uh while while wells chilling
he was approached by a certain gentleman
wearing a hoodie
and the gentleman recognized magnus and
uh inquired as
if he was the the current world chess
champion magnus replied yes this is me
uh and this gentleman asks magnus if
he's interested in one game of chess
uh where if magnus wins uh the hooded
gentleman will donate 1 million dollars
to charity
but if magnus loses magnus must resign
from chess
and magnus thought this was a very funny
and he uh well
uh he didn't play chess that day he
thought it would uh be a
very interesting challenge for him maybe
even you know maybe he could
have some fun and he was uh very
interested in who this person was but he
couldn't really see
because the hoodie was really all over
his face
so it was more of a um i don't know how
to put more
like maybe as if a sith lord approached
you
uh but magnus said yeah sure let's play
a game and they they went into the near
park
uh they put up a chessboard and they
started playing this game
and it's uh it's one of the greatest
games i've ever seen so let's first
check out the game and then see uh
what happened uh so mr md here and
notice that i'm not wearing a hoodie
which means that our mysterious hoodie
guy
might not be so mysterious so uh let's
see what happens here
uh for the moment md opens with e4
we have e5 by magnus knight f3 knight to
c6
and now bishop to c4 magnus plays bishop
to c5 he wants to check if
uh mr hoodie guy here watches my channel
or rather will he go for the evans
gambit and indeed he did he played b4
here and
magnus was very happy about this he saw
that uh the evans gambit is on the board
and he happily accepted the challenge he
played bishop captures on b4
we have c3 as one does when uh faced
with this bishop captures on b4 move
bishop to a5 and now uh
d4 striking the center magnus no
stranger to opening c
accepts the d4 pawn as well and here we
have
castles now asking magnus what do you
want to do here
so here you could do a lot of things g
the e7 is the most solid approach or
rather should be the most solid approach
uh d captures and c3 is a bit maybe too
adventurous
uh but magnus decides to go for d3 it's
a very positional idea
uh that gives back upon where white if
captures then the bishop
moves back from this very active square
and if queen captures then you get some
very nice ideas like then you go knight
g to e7
and well this is just a beautiful
position for black
there's no way for white to actually
take advantage of this you can never go
for something like knight
knight g5 because knight e5 attacks the
queen the bishop defends f7 and so on
so of course um magnus knows this that's
why he win d3 but now bush
queen to b3 putting pressure on f7 and
uh the bishop is still on a5 so magnus
cannot play knight to a5 so
instead we have queen to f6 uh defending
the f7 pawn and now the immediate e5
and magnus was already very impressed
that the mysterious gentleman is playing
with with such ferocity
because the pawn cannot be captured if
the pawn is captured then
we get the simple rookie one and white
wins there is no way to defend because
if d6 then bishop g5
and after you move the queen you still
have to keep an eye on the knight uh
it doesn't really matter what you do
queen f5 now we just capture
we win a piece and that's it the the
piece cannot be recaptured if
if if it is then queen b5 check the
bishop is under attack we're threatening
the rook everything just falls even if
our king to f8 then even queen c5 check
came back
and now rook captures on e5 just wins
the game on the spot
so after e5 magnus says okay this is not
a problem just queen g6
i'm not material i'm defending the d3
pawn that life is just great
so rook to e1 uh getting the rook to the
uh soon to open up
e file and now knight g to e7 magnus now
ready to castle we have bishop to a3 now
white's bishop pair is fully operational
and here while magnus could castle uh
magnus says
all right i see that your bishop pair is
fully operational i really like that i
want my bishop pair to be fully
operational as well and here magnus
decides to give back some material
because that's how you always should
play chess
uh he gives up the b pawn and now he
wants to put his bishops on b6 and also
on b7
and then wreak havoc along this uh well
a beautiful diagonals uh so uh here we
have queen captures on b5 and now
rook to b8 a nice active move with the
rook queen to a4
and now bishop to b6 now this bishop is
a monster and this bishop is coming to
b7
not that arrow chess.com not that arrow
uh knight b to d2 uh and now bishop to
b7 now the bishop
pair is fully operational knight the e4
by mr hoody guy here
and here magnus goes for queen to f5 and
the queen is excellently placed here
uh you can't really do all that much the
f2 pawn is hanging so white has to be
very careful but there is one move that
uh
kind of poses a lot of problems for
magnus and that's bishop captures on d3
now the bishop aligns itself with the
queen some moves like
not that moves like knight to d6 check
would open up an attack towards uh
carlsen's queen so magnus moves it with
a queen to h5
and now uh if black gets the castle then
black will be perfectly fine
uh so here uh mr md starts a a
devastating attack he plays knight to f6
check uh forks the king and queen and
now the knight must be captured
otherwise
magnus needs to part with the queen so g
captures an f6
uh e captures on f6 and now just rook to
g8 now magnus is up so much material
that he simply doesn't care
and uh on top of that his threatening
queen captures an f3 because the g
pawn is pinned uh and here we have a
move that's uh
really really weird uh here mr hoodie
guy plays
rook eight to d1 and magnus is just what
is this this i mean this is uh
nothing special this is like the the
lamest move ever played uh
even though there is one game that was
played uh the you know that reached this
exact same position uh from
1852 was actually played in berlin by
some uh you know
unknown person uh and magnus says all
right thank you for the piece i'm just
going to play queen captures on f3
and i'm gonna threaten checkmate here so
what is the plan here or get those the
100 thousand dollars ready
uh and uh i mean what's happening here
so here uh well uh white if white
doesn't want to get checkmated white
needs to do something
so here rook captures on e7 was played
with check
magnus said all right okay i can i can
live with that just knight captures next
move
i'm going to check made the white king
i'm going to win the money for charity
and i'm gonna you know continue with my
day
however uh here magnus missed a very
very crucial idea
uh so feel free to pause the video here
and try to find
uh this uh well amazing idea that this
totally unknown mysterious person uh
spotted while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on
spotting this well one of the greatest
if not the the greatest move or the
greatest the series of moves
ever played uh and uh for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
it's actually queen captures on d7 but
before playing this queen captures on d7
move
our mysterious person removed the hoodie
and
that was an even bigger shock to magnus
then was this queen sacrifice
because after uh this gentleman removed
his hoodie
magnus saw that it was in fact max
deutsch who he faced
three and a half years ago if you
remember the obsessive learner who
studied chess for one month and then
said that he was going to crush the
world champion
uh here he returns and he's been
training every day
every day for the past three and a half
years to become the ultimate chess
machine
he's been using the uh the same strategy
as alpha zero uh so he just
started by knowing nothing and he just
you know tried everything and you know
if it works it works and this is how he
came upon
such great moves and here while removing
his hoodie
he played queen captures on d7 and this
is where magnus
saw what was happening uh here the king
is in check
and you don't really have a good option
because if you move the king then queen
captures an e7 is checkmate
and if you don't move the king uh well
then you have to capture the queen
and if the queen is captured now comes
bishop to
f5 with a double check this is uh
this is insane uh white always have to
has to move with temple because uh one
one little move and you're getting
checkmated everything is eyeing that
g two pawn the bishop the queen the rook
so everything must come with with tempo
so here the king is in check
and here king e8 magnus goes back
problem is if you go king to c6 then
bishop to d7 is checkmate all of these
squares are now covered
by the by the bishop pair uh this is the
this is the ultimate bishop pair never
in history has there been such
a such a bishop pair maybe once you know
in in berlin in 1852 but but that's it
uh so here instead after bishop to f5
check
king the e8 was played by magnus and now
comes bishop to d7 check
king to f8 or king today doesn't really
matter and here
uh we have bishop captures on e7 uh max
deutsche delivers checkmate and the what
a checkmate it is look at this this is
the
uh never has there been such a such a
fully operational bishop pair that
completely destroys black the pawn is
covering g7 this is just uh
uh an amazing game and you know
such a game never ever ever happened
this is this is just insane
and uh max deutsche got his revenge if
you haven't seen the original video i've
posted the original video some three and
a half years ago
uh it will be the first link in the
description below so do check it out
magnus really crushed max
i took him only only a few moves and max
didn't really know what was going on but
uh it seems the max was uh i don't know
how he got
this good like in three and a half years
it's like he was maybe using a
hyperbolic time chamber to achieve
such power level but this is uh i mean
amazing stuff and
magnus as he is known to be a man of his
word he said that
uh he definitely uh will step down as
the world champion in
all time formats as magnus is the world
champion uh in classical in rapid ending
blitz and he will
uh he will make a formal petition to
fidei to make max
deutsch the world champion in all
formats so now after the
candidates tournament in
in april finishes uh that the winner of
the candidates tournament actually
challenges
max deutsch for the title instead of
magnus carlsen
uh so really really amazing stuff and
max deutsch said that now that he truly
mastered
chess he's done with chess he he you
know he can't stand chess anymore
he just wanted to crush magnets now he's
going to turn his attention over to
tetris he now wants to become the
greatest tetris player of all times
and this is already uh covered by all
the big media in the world so if you
still haven't seen it you know just
google check it out i will put a link
uh the second link in the description
below will be an official article by
chess 24 about this game
uh so do check it out uh as uh well
they've covered it in great length uh
so first thing uh the first game between
max deutsche magnus carlson
i made a video on it three and a half
years ago the second link will be the
article to just 24.
so i'm really really devastating news uh
magnus steps down as the world champion
and we'll see we'll see
what happens if he will honor the
agreement or will he continue playing
and
maybe but who would continue playing
after such a game after after facing
such greatness this could be
could be uh you know the greatest game
that there ever was and will be so
sort of an evergreen game but yeah
really really amazing stuff we'll see
what happens so you know stay
stay tuned uh but yeah that's that's uh
the the video hope you guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank uh cheyenne
javid uh chad smith
derek king eric thomas and kunal parikh
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day